foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
huh
hi uh hello I'm I'm a human being from
the top world
you probably don't understand a word I'm
saying do you of course I understand you
what do you think I am one of those
mindless monsters that's right bub
you're in the presence of the one the
only Yeager dad
dad
whoa baby clade oh is the president
doing in our front yard our entire world
is in grave danger I want you to come
with me on an expedition I'm not my
father he was the Explorer I know you
were just a kid when you went missing
but now you're all we got Mr clade I'm a
huge fan thank you of your dad
where in the world are we Ethan you
brought the dog he just wants to help
yeah
we are clearly in Uncharted Territory
uh hello you probably don't understand a
word I'm saying of course I understand
you huh
get dad Grandpa I'm a grandpa
what is this place the cliffs are alive
and the waters dissolve the flesh off
your bones uh is this thing dangerous
it's so cute I want to merchandise it
they're basically the same person
are you okay
[Music]
a nightmare tunnel just be brave
[Music]
dies
no around them yeah
foreign
[Music]